it's Wednesday August seventeenth I'm
Mary and today we have something for
eyes of all varieties we have a zombie
Metal Gear we have a fighting Harley
Quinn and we have new resident evil
footage if you have eyes you're gonna
light gamespot name first up konami
revealed a trailer for the new metal
gear game today the good news is it's
not pachinko the bad news is it's zombie
survival Konami announced Metal Gear
survived a multiplayer stealth game
coming to xbox one ps4 and PC in 2017
the announcement was made during
gamescom where Konami showed off a
trailer check it out much of the footage
featured in the video was set during the
ending of ground zeroes confirming it is
set after the metal gear solid 5
prologue but that's pretty much where
the similarities end it has no original
team members and it's quite clearly a
zombie survival with new weapons to
match the game will branch out from
traditional pistols and rifles the
series has been known for giving players
the opportunity to master new weaponry
like this bow it does seem a bit strange
that Konami went with zombie survival
for the continuation of the Metal Gear
franchise but it's not the craziest
thing they could have done other ideas
for new Metal Gear games I had work Big
Boss bejeweled metalcraft cooking papa
snakes on a plane the game I've
submitted these two Konami and i'll let
you know their response The Suicide
Squad reviews were a bit mixed but what
wasn't mixed was that everybody loves
harley quinn and Deadshot so good news
they're gonna be an injustice to
injustice to publisher Warner Bros
interactive entertainment released a new
trailer today confirming the additions
of harley quinn and Deadshot to the DC
Comics fighting game injustice to check
them out in this trailer Harley Quinn
appeared in the original injustice as
well but Deadshot's super new just last
month at San Diego comic-con it was
revealed that Wonder Woman and Blue
Beetle would be joining an already
confirmed character roster like Batman
Superman Supergirl Aquaman a bunch of
girls and men sounds really cool and
it's an ever growing roster so this is
nothing but good stuff injustice to the
sequel to 2013's injustice gods among us
is scheduled to release in 2017 for ps4
and Xbox one
ever since Resident Evil fans got their
hands on the latest demo they've been
eager to see more of the game and they
got what they wanted today because there
was a new trailer released for resident
evil 7 Capcom today released a new
trailer for resident evil 7 that teases
new story details check it out depicted
in the video is Marguerite from the
beginning our demo and it had to be
Marguerite because we all know what
happened to that dude from the demo in a
blog post Capcom revealed the graphical
effects of the found footage tape don't
represent what the actual game will look
like we don't know what Marguerite wants
from the young woman or if she'll even
escaped the house whatever the case
she's not a playable character while the
young woman may be the focus of this
particular found footage video taped
segment you will not be playing as her
in the game Capcom has said but there
might be some hints of gameplay from
these clips like Marguerite hiding from
a super creepy lady holding a lantern
and shining it into decrepid spaces
looking for something resident evil 7
was officially announced during Sony's
e3 2016 briefing in June the game
launches on January 24th in 2017 for ps4
xbox one and pc so those were all the
cool trailers revealed today but with
gamescom going on all week I'm sure I'll
have a lot more for you tomorrow so I'll
see you then
you